[Music]
with the popularity of streaming shows
like the boys and Invincible booming I
often wonder why more Buzz wasn't
generated by Netflix's own subversive
comic book adaptation Jupiter's Legacy n
I'm just kidding no one even knows that
exists but more people should definitely
know about super Crooks between
Invincible becoming a Smash Hit and the
ultimate Underdog hit monkey getting a
season 2 somehow I I I feel like I
deserve some credit for that things are
looking up for adult animated comic book
properties but there's another show
that's been out for two whole years and
hasn't really gotten the same
recognition or cult status as the other
two despite being one of my favorite
shows I've watched lately Netflix's
super Crooks is the very unique case of
a western comic being adapted into a
Japanese anime format with what looks to
be a high budget in some really
beautiful animation I generally like to
think that I keep my finger on the pulse
of comic book adaptations but over the
last 2 years this one somehow completely
flew under my radar
probably because I deleted my Netflix
account after that stupid god- awul
password sharing debacle was implemented
but then my wife started to miss all the
krama shows on there and made a new one
even though she wasn't actually going to
watch them so we're basically paying for
it for nothing every month but at least
skimming through there one day after we
had it back for the first time in a year
caused me to accidentally come across
this show this series wonderfully adapts
the four isue Indie comic by Mark marar
and LEL Francis U but also expands on it
and Dives deeper into the story to
ultimately make it even better better
than the Charming comic let me tell you
all the reasons I love super
Crooks the timing of this video is a bit
funny because just as I was planning to
finally make it after mulling it over
for a few weeks writer Mark marar has
been getting repeatedly dunked on on
Twitter even by The Joker somehow and
I'd like to preface this whole review by
saying I'm not a giant fan of his or
anything in fact I've downright hated
some of his stories in the past but it
seemed like the guy was was unavoidable
for someone getting into comics in the
2000s like I was he wrote the ultimates
which is embarrassing in itself but he
also wrote Civil War which is like a
giant disaster where iron man is
supposed to be in the right but the book
never makes a strong case for that so it
just ends with Steve Rogers dead
everyone has a really bitter taste in
their mouth about Tony Stark I like
kickass one all right both the comic and
the movie despite their faults at least
kickass made a strong case for Indie
Comics getting big budget adaptations
again along with all the other Marvel d
C fair but kickass 2 and three are just
gross and unpleasant wanted is just edgy
try hard trash Nemesis is a good premise
ruined by Childish dialogue trouble you
guys remember trouble I owned two copies
of trouble my friend Jacob keeps giving
me copies of trouble you know what's
hilarious I was really into Mark malar
books when I was like 14 and hated
everything and I was angry at the world
I dove into so much of his work at that
stage in my life and naturally at the
time I loved most of it and I realized
that's because I was the exact target
audience for his stories an angry
14-year-old and once I grew out of that
teenage angst mindset I reread a bunch
of them and I wondered what was wrong
with my underdeveloped brain for liking
this stuff but for every edgy
over-the-top Story full of exploitative
shock value and miserable unlikable
characters sometimes he writes something
like Marvel Knight Spider-Man or Huck or
or his run on Superman is actually
really nice I didn't hate his Wolverine
stories actually even if it was pretty
dark every once in a while he drops
something a little bit more hopeful and
positive with a spark of creativity that
makes me second guess my dismissal of
him and then I read the next thing and
then the cycle starts over this takes us
to Super Crooks a 4issue miniseries
published in 2011 with art by lonel
Francis U Philipino represent this is
one of the better Comics I think marar
ever wrote it's about an ambitious super
villain with electric El Powers aptly
named Johnny Bolt Gathering up a crew of
other low-level villains to pull a major
Heist so they can retire from crime and
get their Mentor out of debt to a
ruthless super villain Crime Boss these
guys aren't world domination weather
control machine types they're more like
the kind of guys Spider-Man usually
busts like shocker Rhino Sandman and of
course Electro you know the really blue
collar super villains that just try to
rob banks and rough people up for money
Johnny's big idea to make off with a
huge score for everyone the crew is to
acknowledge a fact that's present in
both Marvel and DC universes there's a
ridiculous amount of superheroes in the
United States but plenty of countries
have none at all so they're off to Spain
where the only superpowers belong to
another long since retired super villain
that they plan to rip off and his
bodyguard a disgraced ex superhero that
was shunned for all of his corruption
and while we don't get to see much of
these characters there's at least
something there to find them all unique
and interesting their personalities and
power sets are on display just enough
enough that I don't think they're
totally boring but they don't get nearly
as much page time as Johnny Bolt and his
telepathic girlfriend Casey and of
course the overall plot feels a little
derivative of Oceans 13 with them all
trying to pull a heist in order to save
an older member of their crew that's
indebted to another criminal but that's
only the broad Strokes the story itself
has a lot of fun comic Booky twists that
use every crew member's powers and a fun
albeit sometimes kind of brutal away
plus it's got really pretty art from the
same guy who drew that cheeked up Peter
par ER turning around into Captain
America but ended up looking like really
sexually charged instead of intimidating
cuz like damn this is like the he's
right behind me isn't he joke but like
done wrong because the person standing
behind them looks a little too sexy uh
is she behind me no I'm in front of you
I only looked up the book after I saw
the Netflix adaptation on my
recommendation much like how I got into
hit monkey when I know there's not much
in the way of source material I always
try to read that first before watching
the anim animated version so I have a
point of reference about what they're
trying to accomplish with that
adaptation and much like hitmon the
anime hits all the high marks for me by
expanding on the source material and
building on what little was there in the
miniseries the first 10 episodes of this
show are kind of like a prequel to The
Comic then the last three are just the
comic after signing a deal with Netflix
to produce shows based on mil's original
Comics only two things have resulted
Jupiter's Legacy and this and I'm pretty
sure no one knows either one exists but
I can attest that the animated one is
definitely at least worth watching I
also want to mention that I wasn't paid
by Netflix to make this review and I
find Netflix to be arguably the
shittiest streaming service out there
because they think every TV series needs
to break a million records in the first
three days or it's a failure so I will
say that this show is pretty good and I
love the English voice cast uh look that
guy's jet from cowboy bbop no the the
the good bbop not the [__] Netflix
man and [__] him I can't believe this
isn't Matt Mercer he sounds identical to
Matt Mercer this is nothing old man I
can keep it up all day I can't think of
a better time to Showcase my style with
animation by Studio bones like I said
before the Super Crooks anime adapts the
four isue Arc as the third Act of the
story they also take time to pull it way
back and give more time for all the
characters to give further context to
their personalities and relationships
and to show how they met and P off a few
previous heists before the events of the
book there's a lot more development for
the individual characters and the
relationships here the first episode in
particular is a dark comedy origin story
about Johnny Bolt developing his powers
as a young superhero fan There's A
Whimsy and excitement and naive hope for
the future then something horrible
happens that I think you just need to
see for yourself that pushes him into a
life of crime I think it adds a lot of
depth to the character to know at one
point he desperately aspired to be a
superhero and it just didn't work out
that way way it's a nice way to have a
criminal main character that we can
still root for because we know he wasn't
inherently down for being a bad guy a
look at him he's just a funny little guy
who probably complains about Spider-Man
2099 costume being the wrong color on
the
internet this is actually the most uh
High selling piece of merch I've ever
put out so go buy even more ironically I
prefer the character designs from the
prequel part of the show before the
events of the book start Johnny looks
fresh as [__] with that facial hair his
status as a super villain is hammered
home more as a character flaw that he's
trying to shake in the series and while
you want to see Johnny finally kick the
habit his adventures are so cool you
also kind of don't my favorite episode
of the series by far has to be episode
three where Johnny and a bunch of his
personal super villain friends Rob
multiple jewelry stores at once and are
beset upon by Legions of police and a
handful of pain in the ass superheroes I
think it's cool to demonstrate firsthand
just how saturated the US is with these
guys to further drive home the point
about why it's a good idea to bring this
team elsewhere later in the series this
episode is essentially all one long
Chase slf fight scene with no
interruptions and it's fun to see all
these powers on display I also think
it's kind of funny this is a world where
the super villains are just Average
Joe's trying to make ends meet and the
superheroes are obnoxious overly brutal
celebrities I often find the boys the
comic not the show irritating for having
no real super villains like at all and
pretty much exclusively focusing on evil
Heroes the world of super Crooks isn't
delved into much in the book but the
show attempts some stronger World
building to mixed results I do like the
idea that some super villains have met
each other before or hung out and others
haven't it's like multiple people in the
same career field getting put on jobs
together but the show also makes an
attempt to come up with an excuse for
why a lot of people have powers without
specific Origins and unfortunately it's
supposed to be a tie-in to Jupiter's
Legacy in some half-ass attempt at a
malar world shared Universe Johnny Bolt
has powers simply because his father who
we never meet or see must have also had
powers or been a descendant of these
mukes from the island in Jupiter's leg
[__] I'm getting tired of saying that
title look this doofus invented X-Men
again how groundbreaking but thankfully
that shit's not important and they don't
really go into it much and with that the
World building is sort of shaky because
the ties to the other show are tenuous
and their character cameos in the middle
of the show feel like weird and annoying
advertisements that didn't need to be
there like you could have had any random
Superman archetype guy in this scene if
anything these bozos showing up makes me
care about piter's leg ay even less
because these guys are markedly less
interesting than the actual super Crooks
the characters here are oozing
personality with great costumes and cool
backstories and fun powers and those
guys are just more morally dubious
Superman send UPS yawn
but they do make a good Mark for a
really cool heist in the middle of the
show imagine breaking into the Hall of
Justice to steal Dr Fate's helmet from
the Justice League God the premise for
this show is so fun I wish Sony would
stop [__] their pants in front of
everyone constantly about the Spider-Man
license and do a superior foes movie
with this kind of tone that comic is
practically designed for a fun action
comedy Heist buddy movie with bumbling
Spider-Man bad guys but no they're over
here doing craving getting radioactive
lion blood why is everything rated R
except the movie with Carnage speaking
of blood and violence this show can get
pretty gory but it's handled Tastefully
I think it's either the result of the
main villain known as the bastard using
his powers to blow up people's heads or
the diesel twins using their really
awesome healing powers I've always
thought healing Factor Powers could be
used in really creative ways and this
show makes a great use of that if there
was ever a Deadpool animated series I I
hope they do [__] with his regeneration
half as cool as this these two are
jumping into propellers getting hacked
apart with lasers and smuggling
themselves into places in suitcases with
their limbs chopped off to better fit in
small spaces I never thought this show
was using extreme violence to be edgy or
gratuitous it's always fun and creative
or at the very least extremely well
animated when they're going for a more
serious tone got to censor some of that
[__] for the YouTubes I also think it's
cool how faithful this series is to the
comic you know with some minor
exceptions that were good changes for
one the bastard is given more of a
direct connection to the super Crooks as
the series progresses because in the
comics they didn't really know him or
have any reason to Target his fortune
other than just well he's rich but now
his old friends turned to enemies with
their mentor and he has multiple run-ins
with them before they choose to Rob him
in the last few episodes plus the show
just treats one of the most badass
characters from the book The Gladiator
with a little bit more love he gets more
action scenes more screen time to show
how he's one of the few morally upright
superheroes in this world and the way
the super Crooks rope him into their
plan is a little less mean-spirited to
me in the book they kind of blackmail
him into helping with the heist because
he's seeing men behind his wife's back
in the show he has a boyfriend instead
of a wife that we see earlier in the
series so it seems less like they're
blackmailing him for being gay and more
just the cheating part so it makes the
events that happen to him in the EP log
sit a little better and I just love him
being voiced by original Leonardo voice
actor Cam
Clark I'm a real superhero you [__]
the other changes that I don't really
mind are things like the decision to
switch the setting for the climax from
Spain to Japan the comic story was come
up with by malar and nacho vigilando who
likely chose Spain for the setting
because it's his home country but the
show screenplay was done by da sat who
likely changed it to Japan because it
was something a little bit more familiar
for the show's crew to work with
depicting as like an alternative to the
US at least that's what I thought it
doesn't affect the actual course of the
story at all but I do find the change
interesting if there's one thing I'll
knock points off for in the series
compared to the comic I'd say the
dialogue in the English dub at least
isn't as Snappy as Mar's script Mark
marar is good at writing chatty
characters with a lot of attitude and
potty mouths but the characters in the
show are a bit more softspoken and
polite by comparison
it works for the villain petorian
because his vulgarity in the comic comes
off as a little bit more childish and
he's more threatening in the show with
his air of classiness despite being such
a brutal monster casting DC Douglas was
an inspired choice for him but some of
the other characters could have
definitely sounded a little bit more
rude and in yourr face I guess that's
what happens when you translate from
English to Japanese back to English
again and yes I watch the show in
English because the dubcast is really
good and my rule is that I prefer the
English version when the characters are
English-speaking characters from an
English-speaking country wouldn't make
sense to watch a Spider-Man anime in
Japanese there a bunch of New Yorkers
forget about it and yes the original
cast is also good so no matter which way
you watch it it'll be a blast along with
hit monkey invincible and spawn I'm
happy this show exists so he can have
some adult oriented superhero stories
and animation if these were on a list of
my favorites in terms of quality I'd
probably do it like this much like the
Marvel anime I reviewed last year this
really makes me wish Japan would take
more cracks at adapting Western comic
stories especially with their style of
adaptation at the risk of sounding like
one of those [__] annoying Japanese
thing better than American thing guys I
do have to admit that I prefer the way
they adapt Comics there in Japan the
manga is your script and storyboard and
the animators take great pains to draw
the characters and locations just like
the manga's personal art style you
really feel feel there's a great respect
for the source material and the
storytellers behind them in the west
it's always someone else putting their
unique spin on it or viewing it through
a new lens or paying tribute while doing
something new and most of the time that
translates to three or four minor plot
points from the comic being used
sometimes in completely different
contexts and if you're really lucky
they'll occasionally use a scene from
the book that happens to be pretty well
known on its own again you usually in a
completely different context aside from
the max 2003 Ninja Turtles and
Invincible the US typically has this
[__] them do it our own way approach to
the adaptations and it's shocking how
rare and infrequent it is to just
animate the story that was already
pretty good comic accuracy is a tricky
thing because sometimes comic books are
confusing messy garbage that needs to be
Whitted down to the broad Strokes to
make sense in a new format and that
works well for some stuff but other
times I get tired of having to see
someone else's unique spin or
reimagining of something because I like
the story already as a comic and I just
thought it' be cool to see that play out
in an animated format there's a world of
difference between static panels on a
page with text bubbles and seeing that
in motion with a good score talented
voice actors and fluid animation it's
especially cool when the art style for
the show looks like the art from the
comic just modified for animation so it
can move well I rar ever get direct
translations for these types of shows so
I treasure any of the ones that do come
out and you know I couldn't give less of
a [__] about a liveaction version of
this if I tried just from the opening
alone I'm positive this could never be
topped in live action look how good they
look they're busting a move around the
same time Jupiter's Legacy got cancelled
my
legacy they also announced the
liveaction adaptation of super Crooks
was coming much like the proposed
liveaction adaptation of invinci ible
it's utterly pointless you already
nailed it in animation this is really
all you needed to do you could have quit
while you were ahead I don't need to see
miscast actors and overdesigned horrible
Renditions of the costumes enacting a
heavily truncated version of a long form
story mashed into a 2-hour format where
they stand around with their masks off
before turning into messy CGI puppets
for poorly choreographed fight scenes
I'm getting tired of that [__] because
I've seen it a million times before and
if I had to choose between the two I'd
say the cartoons are always better
because it looks like a comic book
brought to life most of the time the
liveaction [__] just looks like well
just gray CGI sludge live action always
gets treated as the Beall end all form
of Storytelling as if Comics or
animation or video games aren't good
enough and they need to be turned into a
big budget Hollywood liveaction
adaptation to be legitimized I don't
think Super Crooks needs to be in live
action because I know none of the
awesome stuff that I like in this show
won't look half as good in that format
you nailed it already be proud of that
instead of trying to take it a step
further Netflix greedy bastards they
canceled Santa Clarita diet with all
that being said I do love and recommend
this show in spite of the fact that it's
written by a sort of an annoying dweeb
and produced by a [__] ass streaming
service that constantly destroys any
good ideas they touch and hates
animation somehow a good one slip
through the cracks and it's lucky it
only had to last 13 episodes or else it'
be cut short on a cliffhanger too
I always get mad at YouTube for not
putting my videos in the subscription
box because people will comment finally
Xavier uploads again after all these
years not knowing three other videos
came out within the last month already
so maybe that stupid Bell icon thing
will help you remember I exist if you
want other ways to support the channel
you can always go hit up that patreon
for early videos and exclusive stuff
because it's just a dollar I'm not
kidding it's only $1 Isn't that cool if
everyone who watched this video donated
$1 a month I'd be able to afford a house
for myself so that would be that would
be really cool you can also check out
our merch on tuu or just buy some of my
random stuff on eBay I have a pretty
substantial collection of old toys that
are still in the box in perfect
condition so go take a look in case you
find something you like and lastly since
this is a YouTube video and you probably
play fortnite drop my Creator code
Xavier GM next time you buy a silly
dance or a cool character skin really
helps me out
see you next
[Music]
time